عربيه مستمره في هذه التغطيه لهذا الزلزال
الجديد زلزلين حقيقه الذين ضربات تركيا
حسب اداره الكوارث التركيه زلزال بقوه 6.4
درجات ضرب انطاكيا جنوب تركيا شعر بها
سكان لبنان سوريا وفلسطين ونقلت رويترز عن
شهود عيان ان اصوات انهيار مباني سمعت في
انطاكيا وكانت قدر ارتفعت حصيله ضحايا
الزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب جنوب تركيا في
السادس من هذا الشهر الى
41,156 حاله وفاه وفقا لما اعلنت اداره
الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه اذا نحن نشاهد
الان هذه الصور منها تاي هذه الصور الناس
هي في الخارج هناك حاله هلع وفزع كبيرين
في ارجاء المناطق التي ضربها الزلزال وحتى
المناطق التي ضربتها الهزات الارتداديه
ايضا في لبنان لهذا الارتداديه تقريبا
كانت بمعدل 4.5 درجات رختر البعض يتحدث
بانها استمرت اكثر من 25 ثانيه وكانت قويه
جدا هناك حاله هلع وخوف هذه الصور منها
الشوارع مليئه بالسيارات وبالناس الذين
تركوا بيوتهم جراء هذا الزلزال الذي ضرب
هاتاي وايضا هناك زلزال اخر ضرب انطاكيا
يعدان ايضا هذان الزلزلان من الزلازل
القويه جدا بعد الزلزال الذي ضرب
تركيا في السادس من هذا الشهر اذا نتابع
هذه الصور للناس الذين خرجوا من بيوتهم
واستقلوا سياراتهم او خرجوا الى الطرقات
هناك فزع كبير منذ قليل كنا ايضا تابعنا
صور
للناس في مطار هاتاي ايضا تابعنا كم هي
خائفه حاله الهلع والفزع داخل هذا المطار
نعود ونذكر بانه حصيله القتلى في تركيا
بلغت اكثر من 41 الفا جراء الزلزال الذي
ضربها ضرب جنوب تركيا في السادس من هذا
الشهر واليوم مسلسل الزلازل مستمر في
تركيا ايضا داخل السوريه شمال السوريه
ايضا هناك حاله فزع وهناك انهيار لبعض
المباني حسب المرصد السوري كان نتحدث بانه
هناك انهيار لمباني في اتارب وايضا
كان معنا ايضا بعض الشهود العيان منذ قليل
تحدثوا بان هناك بعض الحالات التي توجهت
الى المشفى الميداني في جنديرس كان هناك
حالات اغماء جراء الخوف نعود ما نذكر بان
هذه المناطق خاصه جنديرس كانت يعني فارغه
من الناس الى حد ما بعد الزلزال الذي ضرب
في هذا الشهر هذه الصور من لبنان مشاهدينا
منطقه شاتيلا في بيروت الناس ايضا على
الطرقات هناك حاله هلع وفزع جراء الهزه
التي ضربت لبنان
وحسب المصادر تتحدث بان هذه الهزه كانت
قوتها
4.5 على مقياس رختر تعد ايضا من الهزات
القويه
اللبنانيون يتحدثون بانه شعروا بهذه الهزه
وبقوتها اكثر من الهزه التي ضربت جراء
زلزال الذي ضرب تركيا في جنوب تركيا في
السادس من هذا الشهر اذا هذه الصور من
منطقه شتيله في بيروت لمن لا يعرف هذه
المنطقه في بيروت هي منطقه مكتظه بالسكان
وهي في بيروت في غرب بيروت
نتحدث ونتابع الان مباشره هذه الصور التي
حقيقه وصلت ليست مباشره وصلت قبل قليل من
منطقه شتيله في بيروت وايضا على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي هناك حاله هلع وفزع
كبيرين من كل المناطق الذين شعروا بهذه
الهزه
غنوه يتيم معي من بيروت غنوه هل انت معي
نعم معك ما الجديد لدينا غنوه
يعني بعض الخبراء يعني هناك تفاوت الان في
الاراء بعض الخبراء يتحدثون عن ان هذه
الهزه التي شعر بها اللبنانيون هي هزه
داخليه مصدرها فالق اليمونه ولكن هم
يقولون بانها ليست بالهزه الخطيره هي كانت
خفيفه بعض الشيء والبعض يقول بانها هزه
ارتداديه لما حدث في تركيا وكانت قوتها
4.5 على مقياس ريختر بكل الاحوال هذه
الهزه بالفعل سببت اهلع لدى المواطنين
لانهم كانت قويه بعض الشيء وشعروا بها
واستمرت حوالي 18 ثانيه
حسب بعض المصادر كان هناك فارق بالوقت بين
منطقه واخرى ولكن معدل التوقيت كانت 18
ثانيه هذا الامر كان كفيل بان يسبب حاله
هلا لدى المواطنين خاصه بعد المشاهد التي
شاهدوها في تركيا وفي سوريا الامر سبب الى
ادى الى نزولهم الى الشوارع وخروجهم من
المنازل خاصه في منطقه طرابلس كان هناك
خروج للمواطنين بطريقه اكثر من المناطق
الاخرى بسبب موضوع تصدع الابنيه وايضا
بسبب تاثر هذه الابنيه بالزلزال الذي الذي
حصل وقع في السادس من فبراير ولكن في كل
مره يعني للاسف في كل مره يحدث فيها هزه
في لبنان هذه الهزه يكون بعدها اطلاق رصاص
بشكل عشوائي وبشكل طائش خاصه في شمال
لبنان وفي طرابلس واليوم هناك حديث عن نقل
طفله الى احدى المستشفيات بسبب اصابتها
برصاصه طائشه بسبب موضوع اطلاق الرصاص بعد
كل هزه وهناك منشدات من المواطنين خاصه في
الشمال بان لا يكون هناك اطلاق للرصاص مع
انتهاء كل هزه
غنوه ابقي معي ولكن مشاهدينا نذكر هذه
الصور التي نتابعها الان هي من حلب في
سوريا ايضا هناك حاله خوف وهلا جراء زلزال
الذي ضرب تركيا حسب اعلام النظام السوري
لا توجد تقارير عن اضرار في الابنيه حتى
الان نتيجه الهزه الارضيه محمد الاشقر من
شمال سوريا الان ينضم الى محمد صف لنا
الوضع لديكم ماذا يجري
نعم يعني في الحقيقه بعد هذه الهزه
الاقتداديه هناك حاله خوف وهلع في عموم
المدنيين هنا في شمال غرب سوريا يعني في
الحقيقه هناك عدد هائل من المدنيين تركوا
منازلهم ونزلوا الى الشوارع الشوارع
ممتلئه الان
المدنيين الذين تركوا منازلهم طبعا
بالنسبه
للاضرار فالى حد هذه اللحظه تتضارب
الانباء التي تصلنا حول انهيار عده مباني
في خصوصا في مدينه سلقين وجنديرس ولكن نحن
بدورنا تواصلنا مع مجلس جنديرس المحلي
وقال ان هناك مباني تصدعت بشكل ازدادت
تصدعاتها وان هناك اقتصرت الاضرار على
انهيار بعض الشرك الى حد هذه اللحظه
وتستمر فرق فرق اداره الكارثه في جنديرس
بالتجوال في احياء المدينه للتحقق من عدم
انهيار اي محمد ناني اذكر الدفاع المدني
ايضا الخوذ البيضاء دعوا المواطنين بعدم
الاقتراب من المنازل المتصدعه
ودعوا ايضا الى الالتزام باجراءات السلامه
نعود ونذكر بمناشده الدفاع المدني
للمواطنين بعدم الاقتراب الى اي مبنى
متصدع وان يلتزموا الاجراءات اجراءات
السلامه تفضل محمد
نعم يعني هناك اما بالنسبه لباقي المناطق
في عموم ريف ادلب وريف حلب هناك تضارب
بالانباء حول سقوط بعض المباني في بعض
المناطق تواصلنا مع الدفاع المدني ولكن
للاسف يبدو الانشغالهم في التحقق من عدم
سقوط مباني لم نتمكن من الوصول اليهم الى
حد هذه
محمد ايضا نتابع هذه الصور المباشره من
ادلب
نتابع الناس قبل قليل وصلتنا نتابع الناس
كيف خرجوا الى الطرقات هناك طبعا حاله خوف
وهلع ايضا في ادلب جراء هذه الهزه التي
شعروا بها منذ قليل اذا هذه الصور هي من
ادلب الناس على الشوارع يبدو الان هذه
الصور من هاتاي من تركيا
ايضا حاله من الخوف والهلع ترافق الناس في
المخيمات الذين يعني اوت الناس
الزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا في السادس من هذا
الشهر
نتابع هذه الصور من هاتاي دعونا نستمع الى
صوت الطبيعي
الله اكبر
هذه سيارات الشرطه ايضا هناك
وحسب
مشهد ايضا بان هناك انقطاع للتيار
الكهربائي وبعد شهود العيان تحدثوا بان
هناك انقطاع للانترنت وانقطاع للتيار
الكهربائي حقيقه مشاهد يعني
قاسيه لهؤلاء الناس الذين لم
يستطيعوا ان ينسم ما حصل منذ اسبوعين
وما زالوا ينمنمون جراحهم من جراء الزلزال
الذي ضرب تركيا في الاسبوع منذ اسبوعين
نتابع ايضا هذه المسنه التي يبدو تعاني من
ضيق في النفس يحاولون اسعافها
حقيقه يعني منذ اسبوعين ونحن نتابع هذه
المشاهد التي تكسر القلب للاطفال المسنين
للشباب الذين يعيشون هذا الخوف الذي لا
يتوقف جراء هذه الزلازل والهلزات الارضيه
التي تضرب تركيا وتضرب ايضا سوريا شمال
سوريا واليوم الهزه الارضيه شعر بها اهل
لبنان وايضا فلسطين حتى حسب مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي ايضا في مصر في بعض المناطق في
مصر ايضا شعروا بهزه لا ادري هذه الصور
الان ما هو مصدرها من اي منطقه ولكن طبعا
نتابع هذه الصور التي تصلنا تبعا
التيار الكهربائي واضح بانه منقطع في هذه
المناطق الخوف يرافق الناس والهلع يرافق
الناس جراء هذه الزلازل وايضا الهزات
الارضيه نعود ونذكر بانه الزلزال الذي ضرب
تركيا اليوم
كان بقوه 6.4 مدينه دفني واخر في سمنداق
بقوه 5.8 فيها لا ادري اذا كان هناك احد
جاهز معي على الهواء رامي عبد الرحمن معي
زميلنا محمود شكر محمود صف لنا الاجواء
لديك ماذا يجري الان في هذه الدقائق
نعم في هذه الدقائق لا شك الى ان هذه
الهزات الارتداديه كانت هي الاصعب لربما
هي الرقم الثالث بعد الهزه الاولى التي
كانت في 6 وبعد ذلك هذا الصباح هذه الهزه
نحن كنا في داخل المدينه شعرنا الى ان
الارض اهتزت بنا لثوان عديده هنا في المدن
وتحديدا التي ضربها الزلزال
نتابع هذه الصور التي وصلت الان محمود
اسمح لي دعنا نتابع هذه الصور لحظه الهزه
الارضيه في ادلب التي ضربت ادلب
رصدتها بعد كاميرات المراقبه نتابع هذه
الصور من شمال غرب سوريا
لكاميرا مراقبه رصدت لحظه هذه الهزه
الارضيه التي ضربت الشمال السوري
دعونا نستمع الى صوت الطبيعي اذا امكن
[تصفيق]
اذا هذه الصور من شمال غرب سوريا
للحظه وقوع الهزه التي ضربت هذه المنطقه
نستمع الى صوت طبيعي
في هذه السوبر نتابع الزراعه
[تصفيق]
يعني حقيقه نحن نتابع الصور والقلب يخفق
من شده الخوف من هذه الصور فكيف للناس
الذين يعيشون هذا الامر بشكل مباشر اعود
اعود الان رامي عبد الرحمن يبدو اصبح ايضا
معنا رامي ماذا لدينا من تفاصيل حول مناطق
شمال غرب سوريا المناطق التي شعرت بهذه
الهزات
شعرت نعم وايضا هناك مساء الخير طبعا هناك
حالات هناك اصابات ولكن اصابات ليس بسقوط
المباني اصابات التي قامت بالقفز
بالطوابق الثاني والثالث خوفا من هذه
الزلزال الجديد حقيقه الامر هناك على
الاقل ما نقل عن 13 اصابه في مناطق ادلب
ومنطقه عفرين الى الان هذه الاصابات
المؤكده وايضا الاصابات
اذا مشاهدينا نتابع هذه الصور لحظه انهيار
بعض المباني فيها تاي ومن المعلوم خلال
تغطيتنا في الاسابيع الماضيه هاتاي كانت
من اكثر المناطق التي تاثرت بالزلزال التي
ضربت تركيا في السادس من هذا الشهر واليوم
ايضا تعود يعود زلزال جديد يضرب هذه
المنطقه
باكثر من خمس درجات تبعنا هذه الصور لسقوط
هذه المباني رامي اعود اليك تفضل
نعم يعني مع الاسف يعني حتى اللحظه هذا
الذي تاكد منه لا نستطيع ان نتاكد من كل
المناطق ونحن نعلم بان الزلزال في المره
الفائته ضرب 123 قريه وبلده ومنطقه لذلك
اقول بان الرقم الذي تتحدث عنه في المناطق
التي تواصلنا معها وتمكنا من التواصل معها
ولكن على ما يبدو بان الخوف والهلع هو
شديد جدا لدى السوريين بكامل تلك المناطق
لا يوجد انسان الان يبات في منزله بعد هذه
الهزه في الشوارع في مناطق سوريا مختلفه
ومع الاسف مع في ظل الزلزال والهزه
الارضيه تعرض تاجر سائق لحاله يعني محاوله
قتل وسرقه مجوهراته من قبل العصابه الناس
تهرب الى الشوارع والاجراء مستمر في بعض
المناطق ونحن ما زلنا نتابع هذه الصور لا
ادري هذه الصور من اي منطقه ولكن كما
نتابع الناس على الطرقات
بشكل طبعا كبير بسبب الخوف ايضا هذه الصور
لحظه الزلزال ضرب ضرب تركيا نتابع هذه
الصور المباشره الان
هذه الصور ايضا كاميرا مراقبه من الغزاويه
شمال سوريا ليست في تركيا هذه الصور لحظه
الهزه القويه التي ضربت المنطقه ايضا
كاميرات مراقبه رصدت لحظه حدوث هذه الهزه
الارضيه من الغزاويه في شمال سوريا
[موسيقى]
طبعا تابعنا الناس كيف تخرج من داخل
المنازل خوفا من انهيار المنازل عليهم
يخرجون الى الطرقات ونعود ونذكر بان
الدفاع المدني ايضا في مناطق الشمال
السوري يقول بانه يجب الابتعاد عن المباني
المتصدعه واتباع اجراءات السلامه
هذه الصور ايضا منها تاينا عضوا نتابعها
في بعض الاحياء في هاتاي الناس طبعا خرجت
الى خارج منازلها هي على الطرقات خوفا من
انهيار المنازل وخاصه بانه هاتاي كانت من
اكثر المناطق تضررا خلال زلزال الذي ضرب
في السادس من هذا الشهر نتابع هذه الصور
لمستشفى يبدو لا ادري اذا كان هذا مشفى هو
مركز
انقاذ
لمسعفين
وبعض المناطق كما نتابع هنا هناك انقطاع
للتيار الكهربائي وايضا حسب بعض شهود
الايام وعلى مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
يتحدثون عن انقطاع الانترنت ايضا
والاتصالات
هذه المنطقه يبدو بان الكهرباء متواجده
فيها
اعود الى زميلنا محمود محمود مال جديد
ماذا ياتيكم من معلومات
نعم الجديد هو انه حتى هذه الثانيه 16 هزه
ارتداديه منذ بدايه الهزه السته على فاصله
عشره التي وقعت عند السواحل التركيه
والسوريه الان منذ خمس دقائق لا زالت
الهزات الارتداديه ولكن بدرجات متفاوته
كان اكثرها السادسه
والاعشار وحده الكوارث التركيه وايضا
الحكومه التركيه تطالب من الناس ان يخلوا
الشوارع في المناطق المهدمه وفي المدن
التي هي بطبيعه الحال مهدمه هي غير غير
يتواجد بها الناس هي تطالب ايضا من
المواطنين الذين هم في المخيمات ان يبقوا
في مخيماتهم وتطالب ايضا ان لا يتجول احد
قرب هذه
بنايات او في الشوارع وهذا ايضا ما حصل
حتى انه كما نشاهد الان من مواطنين هم
ينقلون سريعا من بعض
البيوت التي هي بالطرف ابنيه من طابق الى
هذه الخيام كل الناس هي متسمره في عمليه
ونشاهد ايضا كما تشاهدين معي لاننا في
الواجهه هذه مجموعه من مخيم كبير في
الوراء ظهرنا هنالك مبنى مؤلف من طبقتين
فقط كان كمركز لوجستيا وتحكم
لتقديم الاغاثه الان يخلى كليا من الناس
والمواطنين
والعدد من المواطنين يخرجون الى هذه الخيم
التي هي امامنا حركه السير في الشوارع
الرئيسيه في المدينه التي نحن بها هي
بالاصل معجومه ولكن الناس الذين كانوا
يتوجهون من متطوعين الى فرق اسعاف اخلوا
كل الشوارع المحيطه بشعاع بنايات العاليه
التي يمكن نشاهد الان ونسمع السيارات
الاسعاف التي تخرج من هذا المركز الاغاثه
الى داخل المدينه ولكن نتابع ونحن نتحدث
معك هذه الصور من سلقين ايضا في شمال غرب
سوريا نتابع الناس ايضا على الطرقات طبعا
بعد الزلزال الذي عاشوه منذ اسبوعين الكل
في حاله خوف وهلا ولايه مرسين التركيه هذا
العاجل على شاشه العربيه تطالب المواطنين
بالابتعاد عن السواحل بسبب الزلزال خوفا
من تسونامي وهذه الصور التي نتابعها هي من
سلقين في شمال غرب سوريا للحظه وقوع
الزلزال الاخير في تركيا وطبعا هناك هزات
شعر بها لبنان هناك تفاوت وتضارب
بالمعلومات اذا كانت هذه هزه بسبب
الزلزال في تركيا ام هي هزه داخليه في
لبنان ساذهب الان الى اسطنبول جميله اوشان
مهندسه مدنيه سيده جميله اهلا بك معنا هل
ممكن ان تخبرين اولا
بالوضع في المناطق التي ضربها الزلزال هل
لديكم اي معلومات عنها
يعطيك العافيه المناطق فيها عنتاب انا
متواجده في عنتاب عنتاب الحمد لله لا
اعتقد انه قد وقعت مباني ولكن الناس كلها
نزلت على الشوارع نزلت الى الطرقات خوفا
من تكرار الماسات التي حصلت قبل 14 يوم
موضوع نزول الناس الشوارع امر مهم جدا لان
المباني التي لم يحصل فيها تلدن او تكامل
باليه الانهيار نتيجه هذه الهزات المستمره
سيحصل فيها ميكي نزم انهيار وتنهار كل
الاحوال البلديه تعمل جاهده وتضع مؤشرات
للمباني انها هذه لا يمكن استخدامها هذه
المباني يمكن فقط سحب الاشياء منها وهذا
التوصيف يساعد في استخدام هذه المباني
بهذه المعلومات جميله هل الناس ملتزمه
باجراءات السلامه يعني لا تدخل الى بيوتها
لا تنام فيها وانما فقط اغراضها وتخرج
والله صراحه بعد 14 يوم تعبنا فبعض
الاشخاص اذهب الى المباني على الرغم انها
محررين لا يمكن استخدامها او من النوع
قرطا صار باللغه التركيه اي انه متضرر
جزئيا هناك تاثر بالجمل انشائيه يمكن
استخدامها باخذ الاغراض
بحاجه الى تدعيم الى اعذريني اعذريني
سنتابع هذه الصور ايضا من كاميرا مراقبه
فيها تاي لحظه وقوع الزلزال نحاول ان ناخذ
الصوت الطبيعي اذا كان هناك من امكانيه
يبدو بانه ليس هناك من صوت طبيعي وانما
هذه الصور لكاميرا مراقبه
دعونا نسمعه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
يعني الاحساس من خلال الصور مرعب فكيف
للناس الذين يعيشون هذه الماسات
واختبار مثل هذا الاحساس
والزلزال يضرب او الهزه الارضيه تضرب اعود
اليك جميله الان الابنيه هي متصدعه جراء
زلزالذي وقع منذ اسبوعين هل هناك الان من
خوف ان تنهار كليا بعد هذا الزلزال الذي
ضربها اليوم
جميعها لا اكيد لا لان المباني هناك نوع
متضرر بشكل كبير ويرى ومصنف انه اغير حصار
باللغه التركيه اي انه متضرر بشكل كبير
غير قابل للاستخدام هذه المباني يمكن ان
تقع نتيجه هذه الهزه وهي اصلا محذر من
استخدامها النوع الثاني الذي هو اورتا
خساردو او هو متضرر جزئيا مقابل للتدعيم
قد ينتقل لمرحله الامر حصل وحتى اذا انتقل
الى المرحله
كبير الذي هو قبل الانهيار لم ينهار فيمكن
الخروج منه وعدم استخدامه الان نتيجه
تكرار الهزات قد يتغير حال المبنى من درجه
الى درجه
المنهار او الاغر حفر او المتضرر بشكل
كبير هو اصلا لا يجب استخدامه يجب عدم
الجلوس فيه وهو محذر من البلديه والبلديه
تعمل بشكل متواصل ليل نهار يعني ظهور
جباره التي تقوم الان في مدينه غازي عنتاب
جميله ونحن نتحدث معك ايضا هذه الصور من
هاتاي للحظه وقوع الزلزال حسب كاميرا
مراقبه ايضا نتابع الصوت الطبيعي
نعم نعم بطبيعه الحال الناس الذين كانوا
خرجوا الى الطوابق التي ذات طابق اول او
طابق ثاني هم خرجوا منها ما عدا ذلك
المدينه هي فارغه وكل المدن بالاصل التي
ضربها الزلزال في الفترات الماضيه هي لم
يعود الناس اليها واداره الكوارث مع
الوحدات للهندسه والمهندسين والبلديات
والمحافظه والوالي هم في الايام الماضيه
كانوا يقومون بعمليه اجراء مسح لكل
الابنيه ولكن هذه المساله هي كانت بحاجه
الى مزيد من الوقت لذلك الان تداعيات
الزلزال على المستوى اذا صح التعبير على
المستوى
الانساني من جهه الناس لم يسجل عندنا
ضحايا او يسجل عندنا اصابات هنا في هذه
المدينه او اقله في المدن التي نحن على
تواصل مع المساله الاساسيه هي الهلع
والخوف الذي القى بضلاله كما نشاهد على كل
المدينه
طبعا يعني حقيقه هناك ماساه حصلت منذ
اسبوعين والناس لما تنسى بعد ولم تتعايش
اصلا مع الزلزال الذي ضرب جنوب تركيا منذ
اسبوعين هذه الصور لانهيار مباني في هاتاي
لحظه وقوع الزلزال نعود ونتابعها مجددا
عمده ايضا اكد سقوط بعض المباني وانهيارها
وهناك بعض الاشخاص تحت الانقراض للاسف
يبدو العمده يؤكد بان هناك اشخاص تحت
الانقاض في بعض المباني التي
انهارت جراء هذا الزلزال الجديد الذي ضرب
هاتايد بعض المباني انهارت وهناك بعض
الاشخاص تحت الانقاض نرجو السلامه للجميع
وهذه الصور نعود ونتابعها لانهيار هذه
الابنيه منذ قليل الجراء هذا زلزال الذي
ضرب هاتاي اليوم
وطبعا هو حسب مقياس ريختر 5.8 ويعد ايضا
من الزلازل الكبرى التي ضربت هذه المنطقه
بعد الزلزال الذي ضربها منذ اسبوعين دعونا
نذهب الان الى غنوه لنتابع معها الصوره من
بيروت واليك
نحن الان يعني في منطقه تقع بين الصالون
والنبعه وهي هذه المناطق غادره السكان
منازلهم كما ترين هنا على مساحه خضراء بعض
الشيء يعني
هناك بعض المواطنين الذين يجلسون في مساحه
بعيده عن الابنيه وايضا في يعني مكان ركن
السيارات مواقف السيارات ايضا هناك البعض
المواطنين يمكننا ان نقترب
بشكل اكبر الى الى المكان ربما لنتحدث مع
بعض المواطنين
ليحدثون بانه بعض المواطنه كانت قد مواطنه
اشتكت بان البلديه رغم حدوث الهزات لم
ترسل اي احد لي
لفحص الابنيه لذلك مع كل هزه هم يخافون ان
ان يبقوا داخل ان يبقوا داخل ان يبقى داخل
منازلهم سنحاول
الناس في السيارات وايضا خارج المنازل
ممكن نسالكم اليوم ليش نزلتوا من البيوت
مبسوطين
خايفين خفتوا شو اللي صار اليوم
يعني لهلا بعد ما صار شي خطير بلبنان يعني
شو بيخليكم تنزلوا
ما بعرف هو عمليه خوف يمكن الحمد لله على
السلامه
الخوف الخوف يعني اسم الزلزال بحذيته
والهزه الارضيه بخوفها يعني يجعل الناس
تخافها كيف اذا شعروا بها وخاصه بانه
الابنيه بهذه المناطق هي متصدعه
ايضا قديمه ايضا في هذه المناطق من بيروت
دعيني دعيني الان غنوه اتابع الان هذه
الصور
من دهوك من العراق ايضا يبدو بانهم شعروا
بهذه الهزه في دهوك العراق وهرعوا ايضا
الى الشوارع اذا تصلنا الفيديوهات تباعا
من عده مناطق ومن عده بلدان شعروا بالهزات
حتى الان لا نعرف اذا هذه الهزات هي
مصدرها الزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا ام هي هزات
من فوالق داخل هذه الدول على كل حال عندما
عندما نستطيع طبعا سنتحدث مع خبراء في هذه
في هذا المجال
ليخبرونا اكثر عن بشكل علمي عن هذه
الزلازل التي تضرب تركيا وهذه الهزات
الارضيه التي يشعر بها بعض سكان المناطق
المحاديه لتركيا كلب لبنان وسوريا وايضا
العراق هذه الصور من دهوك زيدان زنجلو
ينضم الي الان زميلنا زيدان الوضع لديك في
اي منطقه وماذا لدينا من تفاصيل ومعلومات
في طريق العوده الى انطاكيا الى هاتاي
في طريق العوده على الطريق السريع شاهدنا
العديد من سيارات الاسعافجه الى هاتاي
يعني هل هو اجراء احترازي ام ان هناك
اعداد او هناك ضحايا حتى لا نعلم لكن رئيس
للاسف اكد بانه هناك انهيار لبعض المساكن
وهناك ناس تحت الانقاض
هناك اشخاص تحت الانقاب بحسب ما اكد
لطفش
عمده قبل قليل لكن كما قلت لكم يعني نحن
نتابع
منذ حوالي ساعه تقريبا في طريق العوده الى
هاتاي ونتابع يعني
المشهد وهناك خارج استقرار كبيره من شرطه
اساسا التي كانت منتشره على هذا الطريق
لافتاح المجال للسيارات الاسعاف
لاكمال طريقها الى هاتاي حتى الان الانباء
الاوليه نعم وكما صبح رئيس بلديه هاتاي
نصف قبل قليل انهيار بعض المباني المتطبعه
وهناك اشخاص تحت الانقاض لا نعلم حقيقه هل
هم من الفرق التي كانت تعمل على ازاله
الانقاض والسائق الاريات الثقيله ام ان
هناك اشخاص فعلا كانوا متواجدين في تلك
المناطق او بجوار المباني المتصدعه عندما
وانا اتحدث معك الان وصلتنا هذه الصور قبل
قليل لمستشفى اضنه لحظه ايضا حصول الزلزال
اذا هذه الصور لمستشفى اضنه لحظه حصول
الزلزال هذا المشفى نتابع هذه الصور التي
وصلتنا منذ قليل لا ادري اذا كان هناك من
صوت طبيعي دعونا نستمع
[موسيقى]
اذا تبعنا اصوات اطفال ويبدو هناك ايضا
خوف كبير خلال هذا الزلزال داخل هذا
المستشفى يبدو بانهم شعروا به بقوه زيدان
اعود اليك تفضل
المشهد الذي شاهدناها قبل قليل في اضنه
المشابه واشد
في حيث تجمع او قرع
العشرات والمئات الى الشوارع رغم انهم
يقيمون في صيام ومخيمات لكنه قراوا بحسب
شهادات عديده ان مواقد النيران التي كانت
تشعل في الشهر
سقطت
او انقلبت بعض مواقف النار التي كان
الاهالي بشكل دوري مساء او في الليل
لتدفئه هناك حاله من الذعر والخوف عند
سكان انطاكيا انهم عاشوا قبل اسبوعين فقط
مراره الزلزال الاول ونكبه الزلزال الاول
واليوم ايضا هناك حاله خلع وخوف شديدين في
شوارع انطاكيا ايضا كما وصلتنا الانباء في
ولايات غازي ابو اورفه ايضا السكان الى
الشوارع ايضا هناك حاله وهلا شديدين
لاسيما
سكان الولايات الجنوبيه
تفيق من صدمه الزلزال الاول اللي ياتي هذا
الزلزال
قبل قليل على احدى تركيا وانا في الطريق
احد خبراء الزلازل صرح بان هذا الزلزال هو
الزلزال مستقل وليس اعتياديه لكن كما ذكرت
يعني ننتظر تاكيدات من افاد هيئه
بالعموم شهدنا اكثر من 11 هزه ارتداديه
الفتره الماضيه معظم هذه معظم هذه الهزات
الاعتداديه قريبه او في محيط هاتاي الهزه
الاولى او الزلزال الاول كان بدرجه 6.4 في
الساعه الثامنه واربع دقائق بتوقيت هاتاي
او بتوقيت تركيا بعد هذا الزلزال
تقطع صوتك يتقطع صوتك زيدان نحن مازلنا
نتابع هذه الصور ايضا هذه الصور من تركيا
قبل قليل وصلتنا جراء هذا الزلزال طبعا
الناس تطمئن على بعضها الخوف ما زال في
قلوب الناس جراء زلزال الذي ضرب جنوب
تركيا منذ اسبوعين
ويبدو بانه ما معي الصحافه منها يمكن ان
يصف لنا المشهد
اهلا بك معنا عمر
نعم انا معكم عمر تفضل هل يمكن ان تصف لنا
الوضع فيها هذه اللحظات
نعم اود الحديث عن انهيار عده مباني الان
في انطاكيا عند مفرق الصمندر تحديدا ولكن
تم انتشال هذه العائله هناك كان عائله
سوريه تم انتشالها من تحت الالقاب
بالاضافه الى ان هناك يمكن ان تطلعها نعم
هذه العائله هي من محافظه اللاذقيه هي
الان بخير الفضل لله تم انتشاله ولكن هناك
لاصابات كبيره للسيده التي تم انقاذها
وزوجها بخير والحمد لله ولكن اود الحديث
ايضا عن حركه كبيره من قريه الريحانيه
او بلده الريحانيه اليوم
سكانها جميعا اليوم عند نزعوا باتجاه معبر
باب الهوى ايضا هناك سقوط عده مباني كانت
متصدعه في الريحانيه ايضا هناك ولكن لا
يوجد اضرار كانت هذه المباني متصدعه وقد
تم اخلائها مسبقا اتحدث قبل ان ادخل الى
ان
جميع السكان هذه البلدتين يعني كانت ليست
علاقه قائمه المباني المتصدعه بالكامل كما
حدث في انطاكيا ولكن انطاكيا
شهدت قبل قليل
انهيار لعده مباني سكنيه كانت متصدعه
بالامس ولكن انهارت بالكامل يوجد بعض
الاصابات ايضا في اماكن عامه في الشوارع
هذا هذا ما شهدناه اليوم
وقبل قليل في في انطاكيا
الحاله اليوم في انطاكيا حاله يرثى لها
جامعه بهذا الزلزال جميع سكان مرسين ومرعش
وغازي عنتاب الان الناس
لولايه مرسين ولايه مرسين تركيا تطالب
المواطنين نعود ونذكر بالابتعاد عن
السواحل بسبب الزلازل الاخيره خشيه من
تسونامي وايضا نعود ونذكر هذه الصور الان
من كاميرا مراقبه فيها تاي لحظه وقوع
الزلزال ايضا نتابع الصوت الطبيعي
[موسيقى]
اذا هذه من صوره هذه صوره من كاميرا
مراقبه ايضا رصدت الزلزال لحظه حدوثه في
منطقه هاتاي منطقه هاتاي التي تضررت كثيرا
ما كانت من اكثر المناطق الضارورا في
الزلزال الذي ضرب جنوب تركيا منذ اسبوعين
وكان عدد القتلى ايضا فيها للاسف كبير جدا
الان هناك انهيار لبعض المباني وصل نعود
ونذكر بان وصل قتل زلزال الذي ضرب جنوب
تركيا والذي كان بقوه اكثر من سته على
مقياس رختر اكثر من 41 الف قتيل في تركيا
وحدها بينما بسوريا هناك اكثر من 7000
الذين قضوا جراء هذا الزلزال الذي ضرب
المناطق التركيه نعود ونذكر ايضا بالنسبه
لموضوع ولايه مرسين تركيا تطالب المواطنين
بالابتعاد بسبب الزلزال الاخير ايضا هناك
دائما بالنسبه للدفاع المدني والخوض
البيضاء في سوريا يقولون بانهم يطلبون من
المواطنين عدم الاقتراب من اي مباني
متصدعه وبان يلتزموا باجراءات السلامه كنا
تابعنا خلال هذه الساعه صور من الغزاويه
في شمال سوريا للحظه وقوع الزلزال ايضا
تابعنا لحظه انهيار عده مباني في هاتاي
الان تاتيني معلومات ايضا هناك انتشال
انتشار للدفاع المدني في ادلب في شمال غرب
سوريا تلبيه لنداء المواطنين وخوفا من
انهيار بعض المباني التي كانت متصدعه
نتابع صوت الطبيعي
المدنيين من مشاه وسيارات هذا الاختصاص
سببه حدوث هزه افتداديه اصابت المنطقه طرق
دفاع المدني تعمل على التفقد الطرقات
والامنيه المتصدعه داخل المدينه والحمد
لله لم يتم تسجيل اي اصابه داخل المدينه
اذا مشاهدينا تابعنا هذه الرساله من قبل
الدفاع المدني في شمال غرب سوريا ايضا
يبدو بانه لا اصابات الحمد لله في ادلب
حتى الان نرجو نرجو ان تبقى الامور
الخسائر على الماديات وعلى المباني وان لا
يكون هناك اعداد لخسائر بشريه كما حصل منذ
اسبوعين الان لدي احد من جنديرس
رمضان سليمان ينضم الي الان من عفرين شمال
سوريا ماذا يمكن ان تطلعنا كيف هو الوضع
في عفرين ماذا نعرف عن جنديرس التي كانت
متضرره كثيرا جراء زلزال الذي ضرب منذ
اسبوعين
يبدو بانه غير جاهز معي ابراهيم الادلبي
معي ابراهيم الوضع لديك ماذا لدينا من
معلومات
مساء الخير دكتور
اكثر من 40 دقيقه كان هناك زلزالان اضافه
الى عدد من الهزات الارتداديه التي قربت
استهداف المنطقه الجنوبيه من تركيا وايضا
المنطقه الشماليه من سوريا وشعر بها عدد
من سكان بيروت هذه الهزه حتى الان اقتصرت
فقط على بعض الاضرار الماديه في ما يقارب
20 منشاه كانت بالاساس متصدعه واختفر عدد
اصابات على 13 اصابات لعموم المنطقه
الشماليه الغربيه من سوريا حيث تركز
الاصابات في كل من جنديرس اضافه الى
الاثار الشريف حلب الغربي الدفاع المدني
كانت قد توجهت باتجاه مدينه لا تعرف وذلك
بسبب استغاثه من الكبد المدنيين
المتواجدين في المدينه للبلاغ عن بعض
المصابين والكحه الالقاب فيما ايضا اقتصرت
على كما تحدثت على الاضرار الخفيفه
المنشات المتصدعه او كانت هناك مناشدات
للمدني بالابتعاد عنها المباني المتصدعه
والخروج بعيدا عنها وايضا الابتعاد عنها
التجمع ايها الخيام الايوائيه وذلك فقط
لمرحله مؤقته بينما يتم فتح الطرقات او
تدارك الوضع من اجل معرفه ما اذا كان هناك
سيرفعها الذات ارتداديه او زلزال او سيكون
الوضع مستقر لعوده بعض النازحين باتجاه ان
كان قيامهم او حتى بعض المشاهد لاستخراج
ما هو من الادوات الضروريه لقضاء هذه
الليله خاصه ان الاغلبيه يفضل المبيت في
العراء على العوده على المنشات السكنيه
ابراهيم ما هي ما هي هناك رساله يبدو من
احد
رمضان رمضان ينضم الينا الان
وين متواجد رمضان الان
نحن في مدينه جنديرس نعم
بالنسبه لمدينه جنديرس اصبحت
للاهالي وخرجوا الاهالي الى الشوارع ولا
يوجد اماكن امنه من اجل الهروب اليها حتى
انا ذهبت بنفسي الى المشفى الميداني من
اجل ان نرى ماذا يحدث في المدينه حتى
الدكاتره والممرضين خرجوا من المبنى الى
الشوارع
حاله رعب كبيره موجوده في مدينه جنديرس
انهارا
ابنيه العدد اثنان بسبب التصدع القديم من
الزلزال الاخير
انهارت عنا مئذنه ماذنه جامع عبد الرحمن
بالعوف هي كمان كانت هذه الماذنه متصدعه
وانهارت الان في هذا الزلزال
عدد الجدران متصدعه من المباني كانت كثيره
الاصابات كانت طفيفه الحمد لله نتيجه لا
التي عقلت هذه ولا يوجد لدينا اي شهداء في
مدينه جنديرس ولكن
اذكر بالاخبار العجل التي ترد على شاشه
العربيه الان وزير داخليه تركيا يقول
وصلتنا بلاغات عن سقوط مباني في ثمن داغ
وانطاكيا جراء الزلزال الاخير بالنسبه
لحاكم انطاليا التركيه يطالب المواطنين
بالابتعاد عن سواحل البحر حقيقه يبدو بان
هناك تخوفات من تسونامي هذه الخريطه الان
لانطاكيا مركز الزلزال نتابعها سويا ايضا
على شاشه العربيه والذي شعر بها الكثير من
الدول المحاذيه لتركيا منها سوريا ولبنان
وايضا فلسطين شعرت بها وايضا على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي كنا تبعنا بان بعض
الاشخاص في بعض المناطق في مصر شعره ايضا
بهزه نعود ونذكر بانه حتى الان ليس لدينا
من معلومات اذا كانت هذه الهزه التي ضربت
لبنان هي داخليه ام هي جراء زلزال الذي
ضرب تركيا هذه الان من اضنه التركيه ايضا
الناس على الشوارع
ونعود ونذكر ايضا في بعض المناطق التي
ضربها الزلزال هناك انقطاع للتيار
الكهربائي ولكن باطن يبدو بان التيار
الكهربائي لم ينقطع هناك ايضا صعوبه في
الاتصالات والانترنت في المناطق القريبه
جدا من مركز الزلزال منها طبعا
حيث وقع هذا الزلزال اليوم
ايضا تم انتشال عائله سوريه من تحت
الانقاض والحمد لله هي سليمه ايضا عمده
هاتاي كان اتحدث بانه حقيقه هناك انهيار
اكد انهيار مباني وقال للاسف بان هناك ناس
تحت الانقاض نرجو طبعا ان يقوموا
بانتشالهم وانقاذهم وان يكونوا بخير وزير
داخليه تركيا يقول اربع اشخاص تحت الانقاض
في انطاكيا اذا حسب وزير داخليه تركيا
اربع اشخاص تحت الانقاض في انطاكيا زميلنا
زيدان زين كان تحدث معنا منذ قليل وقال في
طريقه الى انطاكيا كان يشاهد فرق الاسعاف
والانقاذ منتشره في كل مكان فنرجو طبعا ان
يتم انتشال العالقين من تحت الانقاد وان
يكونوا بصحه جيده من جنديرس ما زال معي
نعم تفضل
الوضع في المدينه لحد هذه اللحظه يوجد
اهالي في الشوارع
الاهالي لا يستطيعون العوده الى منازلهم
لان المنازل بشكل تصدع كبير في هذه منطقه
جنديرس تعتبر منطقه منكوبه لا كهرباء ولا
ماء وحتى شبكات الانترنت لا توجد منذ
لحظات الاولى
لسقوط الابنيه في المدينه انقطعت الانترنت
عن هذه المنطقه ولكن حاليا انا كنت متواجد
امام المشفى الميداني في المدينه جنديرس
اتت حالات
اغماء من بعض النساء والاطفال نتيجه الخوف
والرعب الذي رمضان اعذرني ولكن الان
الرئاسه التركيه تطالب المواطنين
بالابتعاد عن البحر خشيه ارتفاع منسوب
المياه اذا الرئاسه التركيه تطالب
المواطنين بالابتعاد عن البحر خشيه ارتفاع
منسوب المياه هناك تخوفات ايضا من ارتفاع
منسوب مياه
وايضا بالنسبه للخوف من تسونامي يعني نرجو
ان يكون معنا اي خبير جيولوجي ليطلعنا
ايضا على الوضع الان وللاجابه على كل هذه
التخوفات طبعا نحاول ان نتصل بخبراء
جيولوجيين ليطلعون على هذا الامر طبعا
تغطيه العربيه مستمره اذا لم يكنوا معنا
في هذه الساعه طبعا يكونوا معنا في
الساعات المقبله بالنسبه للساحل السوري
ماذا لدينا رمضان هل لديكم اي معلومات
يعني التخوف ايضا من الساحه التركيه
ويطالبون بالابتعاد عن البحر خشيه ارتفاع
منسوب المياه هل لديكم اي معلومات عن
الساحل السوري
نحن في مدينه جنديرس لا يوجد لدينا حتى
شبكه انترنت من اجل ان نتواصل مع الناس في
شبكه في الساحل السوري طبعا نحن في
المدينه طلبوا منا
عمه على المجموعات بابتعاد الاهالي عن
الابنيه المتضرره
عازرني رمضان نذهب الى نائب الرئيس التركي
الان
يفكروا في صحتكم في عائلتكم في اولادكم في
ازواجكم في زوجاتكم نرجو عدم الدخول
والتوجه الى تلك المباني بعون الله نحن
سنقوم بتعويضكم بجميع الاموال والحاجات
ولكن لا نستطيع ان نقوم بارجاع نفس واحده
خسرناها جميع الوزارات والمديريات
والمدراء والفرق موجودون في الساحه
يتابعون جميع المواضيع والمستجدات عن كسب
هذه كانت اخر التحديثات لا توجد هنالك اي
قال لك لا توجد هنالك اي اخبار سيئه
الفراق الهيئات
جميع
الوزراء الاليات العمال
موجودون
بامكان المواطنين الوصول للقوات المسلحه
او القوات الامن داخل الموجودين في
الساحات او هيئات الكوارث الطبيعيه
لابلاغهم وتلقي الخدمات مره اخرى اسال
الله السلامه لجميع المواطنين
احنا كنا مع نائب الرئيس التركي في اجازه
صحفي بعد هذا الزلزال حقيقه الزلزلين
لدينا ضرباء تركيا في
انطاكيا وايضا في مدينه دفني كان بقوه 6.4
في مدينه دفنه بينما فيها تاي في سمنداغ
5.8
نائب الرئيس التركي اتمنى من الناس بان
يحافظوا على سلامتهم وان لا يقتربوا من
بيوتهم
المتصدعه
وايضا وعدهم بانهم سيعودون الى بيوتهم
قريبا بيوت طبعا طبعا بيوت جديده بدل
البيوت
المتضرره
وايضا
حتى الان هناك ثمانيه اصابات حسب نائب
الرئيس التركي هناك تسجيل ل 20 هزه
ارتداديه منذ وقوع الزلزال الجديد في
هاتاي اذا عش
هاتاي اخر المعلومات حسب نائب الرئيس
التركي بانه حتى الان لا خسائر بشريه
وانما هناك ثمانيه اصابات تم تاكيد بان
هناك مباني انهارت جراء هذين الزلزلين
الجديدين ايضا هذه الصوره التي تطلعنا على
مركز الزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا وهو انطاكيا
والذي شعر به شعرت به الدول المحاديه
لتركيا وانما نعود ونذكر بان هناك تضارب
بمعلومات هزت لبنان اذا كانت هي من الداخل
فارق داخلي ام هي جراء زلزال الذي ضرب
تركيا حتى الان لا قتل الحمد لله هناك
اصابات نرجو السلامه للجميع طبعا فرق
الانقاذ منتشره في تركيا حسب زميلنا زيدان
زنجلو في جنديرس ايضا رمضان كان معنا منذ
قليل وقال بانه هناك حالات اغماء حالات
خوفه وهلع ولكن الحمد لله ليس هناك من اي
اصابات بالنسبه لي ايضا الدعوات في تركيا
بعدم الاقتراب من البحر خشيت ارتفاع منسوب
مياه البحر وهناك بعض اخر ايضا يتخوفون من
تسونامي ونائب رئيس تركيا يقول لا داعي
للقلق من ارتفاع مستوى البحر بعد الزلزال
الان لحظه
الهزه في حلب
في احدى محطات الوقود في حلب هذه الكاميرا
رصدت لحظه الزلزال الذي وقع في تركيا
وايضا كان هناك هزه شعروا بها في ريف حلب
هل هناك من صوت طبيعي
اذا لحظه الزلزال في مدينه
الباب في ريف حلب ابراهيم الادلبي ما زال
معي
ابراهيم هل لديك اي جديد
حتى الان الجديد هو الافضل انه لا يوجد
اعداد لم يسجل حتى الان
فالمنطقه
نتحدث فقط عن محاوله لتعيين الاضرار
واحصائها العديد من المدن والقرى المحاذيه
في ريف حلب اكدوا ان الاضرار فقط اتصلت
على الماديات وهذا امر ايجابي فقط كما
تحدثت في مدينه الاقارب كان هناك نداءات
لتحرك سيارات الدفاع المدني والاسعاف من
اجل المحاوله للمساعده لم لم تصدر اي
تاكيدات حتى الان عن وجود قتلى في مدينه
الاقارب في عموم في سرمدا اضافه الى حارم
تقتصر الامر فقط على تهدم في المنازل
المتصدئه وما رافق ذلك طبعا اضيف المدنيين
عشرات الالاف من المدنيين ما في هذه
اللحظه ما زالوا متواجدين في الشوارع
والعرعر ممن خرجوا من المشاه السكنيه وحتى
من المراكز اللوائيه خشيه من تكرار الهزات
التي قد تؤدي الى تساقط تساقط الامور فوق
روسيا او جدران المنازل حتى الخيام
بالنسبه لموضوع الاتصالات هل ايضا تاثر
بهذا الزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا
ليس كل المناطق اشعرت بموضوع الاتصالات
هناك بعض المناطق التي لا نجد صعوبه
بايجاد شبكه الاتصال ومناطق اخرى يكون
الانترنت اكثر استخداما من شبكات الاتصال
الشماليه الغربيه من سوريا تعتمد على جزء
كبير منها على الامبيرات او الميرار
الاشتراكات المحليه عندما تحدث هكذا نوع
من الكوارث الطبيعيه تم اطفاء الاناره من
اجل الحفاظ والامبيرات او المولدات
الكبيره من اجل الحفاظ على سلامه الشبكات
فقط
اسمح لي ابراهيم هذه الصور ايضا من هاتاي
لمباني مدمره نستمع الى الصوت الطبيعي
هكذا
اذا تبعنا هذه الصور ايضا منها تاي لمباني
مدمره وايضا الناس خائفه تهلا كان هناك
ايضا
لمشهد لفرق انقاذ متواجده في هذه المنطقه
في هاتاي طبعا الكهرباء منقطعه في هذه
المناطق
مازلنا نتابع هذه الصور للدمار الذي خلفه
هذا الزلزال الذي ضرب انطاكيا حتى الان
هذا الزلزال هو
بقوه
5.8
في هاتاي اما في مدينه دفني كان بقوه
6.4% حسب المعلومات التي وصلت حتى الان
ايضا بعض المعلومات تحدثت عن انهيار مباني
في الداخل السوري وايضا بالنسبه لتركيا تم
تاكيد انهيار بعض المباني واصابات ثمانيه
اشخاص ولكن الحمد لله حتى الان
لا حديث عن اي قتيل نائب رئيس تركيا يقول
بانه لا مخاوف من ارتفاع منسوب مياه البحر
حتى الان لانه في بعض المناطق او بعض
المسؤولين كانوا تحدثوا وتمنوا على الناس
ان ابتعدوا عن البحر خوفا من ارتفاع منسوب
المياه في البحر ولكن نائب رئيس تركيا قال
لا داعي للخوف من هذا الامر واكد بان هناك
ثماني اصابات حتى الان جراء هذا
زلزال الاخير فيها تاي نرجو السلامه
للجميع ونامل ان يتوقف مسلسل الزلازل
والهزات